and then / - what happens here's one
there's this there's the first one
you're asking me to add it add it to the
other one right and then what was the
other thing you asked me to do
/ - so I'm gonna take that thing and
then once I get something out of it I'm
gonna divide by two okay so let's just
see what happens what would you like me
to do next what what piece of working
could I do on this I really hope we can
simplify this can someone give me a
suggestion for how I can serve it okay
I've got an answer but I want to know
how to simplify it all right I want to
know how to get there okay I've got two
fractions what's your normal impulse
your normal instinct when you're at two
fractions what do you do you could you
could cross multiply to get a common
denominator right it said we already
have a common denominator so we just add
them together right so I'm gonna get
minus 5 minus 3 root 5 plus -5 Plus 3
root 5 all over 2 right common
denominator and don't forget that whole
thing is being divided by 2 okay that
looks good to me so far we've got all
these gross thirds hanging around right
did you loosen this too what happens to
them they exactly cancel out do you gets
a coincidence like they just happen to
cancel out should I make them vote
rustling you said it's a quadratic it's
a quadratic equation here we had another
word for this right what do we actually
use the formula it's got a plus and a
minus in it right it will always have a
plus or minus in it you'll always have
the third bit is plus and minus so they
just cancel out did you notice that so
what do I get here minus 5 minus 5
what's that - 5 minus 5 it's minus 10
you've just told me those surd parts
will just cancel each other out that's
divided by 2 and then you divide by 2
- five on two as we heard before okay so
where is that that's negative two and a
half right where does that look like do
you think are you happy with where I
positioned it roughly yeah all right and
it's nice it's like oh look that doesn't
have any sad bits I can write that
pretty easily on okay now what you've
just worked out is where the exodus
sushi is cheb out of you have a question
ah so you say that one more time but
loudest so everyone can hear can't we
just do X equation x equals 10 XI minus
B over 2a
think about this hold on hold on let's
just we have a hypothesis here let's
just see if works out a and B what are a
and B in this there's whoops sorry
there's a right there it's a 1 and then
here is B it's 5 right so if I put that
into here I would say x equals minus 5
over - lots of one which is of course
this now hold on a minute hold on a
minute
how did how did this such ultra simple
thing come out of this like
mind-boggling disaster can someone tell
me where say that again but lesser
everyone can hear it came from this plus
or minus square root of right you told
me to find an average you should add the
two things together / - right but if you
add something together one with which
has a plus and which which has a minus
they will always every time cancel each
other out right the plus and the minus
will always cancel each other out
we took the really scenic route didn't
we
right so in fact we can go directly here
because this grows part near the plus or
minus it will always every time cancel
out is that okay in fact what you're
really doing is minus B on to a plus
minus B on
to a and then you divide it by two which
takes you exactly yeah okay which is why
I've artfully left this little gap here
right the axis of symmetry if you want
you can take the scenic route or now
that we know why and that was really
important I didn't just want to land you
on an equation here you go
right and then it just mysteriously just
kind of like it's there right it comes
from somewhere it came from you taking
these two things out of the quadratic
formula and then taking the average
right and that's what you end up with
one last question why is it x equals y
not say y equals the axis is symmetry
what kind of I've drawn it on what kind
of line is it which directions are
facing it's vertical right all vertical
lines are in the form x equals x equals
zero x equals five in this case one x
equals minus two and a half in fact I go
so far as to encourage you to write that
onto the line itself right it has an
equation you can label it just like
everything else that is going to be on
there okay we have access to symmetry
that's going to lead to the vertex of
the turning point I've really um I've
pushed your brain a lot and asked you a
lot of questions so at this point I'm
just going to show you how we get it
okay
the vertex the turning point right you
can take your x value out of this in
this case it's negative two and a half
right and you're going to say substitute
that that x value right substitute oops
wrong color sorry we're going to
substitute into the original equation
the equation we started with so
substitute right the axis of symmetry
whatever it happens to be into the
original equation
now at this point I'm going to encourage
you to reach for your calculator because
I'm sure you probably could work out
what negative 2 & 1/2 squared is and
then some add it to 5 lots of that etc
but this is just sort of machinery right
get the machine to do it okay so has
someone already worked out when they put
it in would you get negative 11 now this
is really interesting right negative 11
what do you think of my graph now does
that look like negative 11 to you
negative negative eleven point two five
thank you so in this case y equals y a
chord okay so I'm gonna pair this
together with the x coordinate to make a
point a point is two coordinates right
so the turning point in this case in
this particular example is what was the
x coordinate it was from the axis of
symmetry what's the x coordinate do you
know one tell you to pack up
thank you negative two enough and we
just worked out the y coordinate
negative eleven and a half now I'm sorry
a quarter what do you think of my graph
now very different cuz this guy here
where should it be what is on the Left
it's on the left it needs to go down
doesn't it see how that's negative 5
that's negative 5 right I'm saying
that's negative 5 negative 11 in the
quarter is like twice more than twice as
far away right so in fact my real graph
should go much steeper do you agree with
that do you see why don't move do you
see why it was useful to get every piece
of information before we actually
started drawing cuz now I've got to rub
out my drawing start again does that
make sense